continues good morning as promised on
the screen congressman Bernie Sanders of
Vermont and today mr. Sanders will be
presenting a piece of legislation that
is going through Congress as an
amendment to the science state and
justice legislation but it has to deal
with a provision of the Patriot Act
section 215 and he has been out talking
about since the Patriot bill became a
law
what does 215 do well with 215 what my
concern is is that 215 as currently
written allows the FBI to go into a
library and say we would like Susan
Swain's reading records ah and they can
get those records without really giving
probable cause as to why they think you
or anybody else in America is in fact a
terrorist all of us are concerned about
terrorism all of us want the government
to do everything that we can to protect
the American people but I don't think we
want to give a blank check to the FBI or
any government agency basically to walk
into it as a secret court and say to a
judge judge we're doing an investigation
on terrorism and the judge then really
has no option but to say okay you can go
in and get the reading records in a
library or a bookstore
regardless without having made the case
to a judge and independent judiciary
that somebody is in fact a terrorist why
does the judge have no option because
the way the language is written is that
if the FBI says that we're doing an
investigation on international terrorism
which they certainly are the judge says
okay you can go in so sometimes our
opponents on this thing will say well
this they have to get permission from a
judge but really that's not the case
while they do the judge has no option
given the like way that the bill is
written and I think there is a lot of
anxiety in America today you know we
have a lot of economic problems middle
class is shrinking the gap between the
rich and the poor is growing wider
health care system is in trouble people
are concerned about the war in Iraq and
people are feeling very uneasy about
losing their privacy rights and allowing
the government to have more and more
power to spy on us if you like and Susan
one of the aspects of this legislation
that interests me is I am a progress
have been proud of it but we have been
working with some of the most
conservative members of Congress who I
think as honest conservatives believe in
limited government and they do not
believe that we should be giving the
government the power to monitor the
reading habits of the American people
our legislation our efforts are also
being supported by the American Library
Association the American Booksellers
Association and millions of Americans
all over this country have expressed
concerns about various aspects of the
Patriot Act and to that end yesterday in
the Washington's there was a front-page
story with this headline conservatives
liberals aligned against Patriot Act bar
in this former representative Bob Barr
of Georgia leads fight to derail Bush's
renewal priority let me just have people
understand a little bit about the
process here when the Patriot Act became
law there were a number of key
provisions that were intended to sunset
in various years so the Congress would
have a chance to revisit the turkey is
this one of them yes and so therefore
what's going on right now is an
appropriately time discussion about
whether or not this works it is this is
in fact a separate effort from the
overall analysis of the USA PATRIOT Act
this is taking place within the context
of the Commerce justice state
appropriations bill that is coming to
the floor today one of the concerns that
many of us have is that the current
Republican leadership has not allowed a
whole lot of amendments to come to the
floor in opposition to what they are
trying to do so we're seizing this
opportunity to essentially say the
Justice Department cannot use federal
money to go into libraries and books
laws now I want to tell you a little bit
of history on this bill last summer we
brought this amendment up and we had
widespread support from the Democrats
almost all Democrats voted for the
hummin independent Democrats voted for
it we had a lot of support from
Republicans at the end of regulation
time we were ahead I my memory is
correct by about 18 votes and I said Ye
we won a major victory a lot of people
concerned about the patriarchy this is
the first victory you know what happened
Tom DeLay and the Republican leadership
simply refused to gavel the vote down
and in the next twenty minutes beyond
the normal time we have 17 minutes of
what they kept the voting rolls open
went around twisting Republican arms we
lost 10 votes and we lost that vote on a
2 to 2 to 10 to 2 10 tie and there was a
lot of people who are really angry when
delay and these other folks were saying
don't worry about us in pinching on
democratic rights in America you can
trust us and then they kept the voting
rolls open for an extra 20 minutes in
order to twist stops so that left a very
bad taste
I think it's gonna be a very close vote
again I think it's gonna come down to a
few votes I think we got a shot at it
it's gonna be close now we are going to
get some calls here
saying that you're soft on terrorism
you've heard the criticism as you throw
it around
what's your response no nobody is soft
on terrorism in the United States
Congress I hope everybody understands
the terrorism is a very serious threat
it is quite possible tragic that there
may be another attack on the United
States when we have got to do as a
country everything that we can to
protect the American people from
terrorism but the issue is and this
reunites conservatives and progressives
can we effectively fight terrorism and
protect the American people without
undermining the constitutional rights
which have made us a free country that's
the issue and I feel very very strongly
that it is wrong to give up our basic
freedoms that is not what we should be
doing and you're seeing a lot of people
coming together to say yeah fight
terrorism or protect our constitutional
rights before we go to cause then what
would you specifically do to change the
process on to fighting what today's
legislation is about is a very simple
one it's simply our amendment simply
takes out libraries and bookstores from
the language that the FBI can
investigate so they will not be able to
go into libraries and books less they
would not be able to monitor the reading
habits of the American people and the
reason I'm doing that is that librarians
in Vermont and all over this country are
telling me we don't want when people go
into the library and they take out a
book you know maybe it's a biography of
Osama bin Laden maybe it's a book on
terrorism they don't want somebody
monitoring their reading habits and
thinking that there are terrorism
because they're reading a certain book
we don't want kids not to be looking at
certain ideas because somebody may think
they're a terrorist it creates a kind of
intellectual chill in America so if in
the course of investigation it is
determined that
these kinds of records should be
searched then how would very simple
Susan and that's a good question
historically traditionally the FBI has
been going able to go into libraries has
been able to go into books lists
I believe they should be able to if they
make the case that somebody is a
terrorist then they need to investigate
that person and go into a library books
look I want them to do that we all want
them to do that but they have to make
the case there has to be some judicial
oversight you just can't go in there and
say we're doing an independent
investigation
maybe somebody wrote a letter to the
editor critical of the President of the
United States we're gonna go investigate
their reading habits is that what we
want I don't think so but if the FBI can
make that case go for it we want them go
after the terrorists and be successful
in that effort just two clarifications
it's a patriot law require reporting to
Congress on how the various provisions
are in fact being conducted I'm asking
that because do you know how this
provision how often it's beneath SDI has
the Justice Department has told us that
since 9/11 for libraries and books laws
it has not been used at all and our log
that's what they say now you know we
live at a time when there's a lot of
skepticism about what anybody in
government is saying that is what they
say and our argument is if it lasts five
years you haven't used it why do you
have to make librarians and booksellers
nervous all over this country
Georgetown Maryland you're first up for
Mr Sanders you're on the air yes I am
Democrat but I really support the things
that you're trying to do I'm just
concerned about how you're going to get
around this lockdown with Tom DeLay this
time and what chance does this have to
to garner have you counted the votes in
other words and I think one of the
problems is because it's such a lockdown
in Republican control right now
there's no hearings about anything and I
think people deserve to hear and
nobody's calling any hearings on
numerous numerous items and what do you
think the chances are this is going to
get through this time Barry as I
indicated last time we lost on a - 10 -
10 vote the president of the United
States has said that he will veto the
legislation if my amendment passes I
think you're going to come down to the
wire I think we'll probably win by a few
votes we'll lose by a few votes we're
working very hard on it and I think the
American people do need to hear a lot
more debate on this issue everybody
wants to fight terrorism and and protect
the American people but we want to do it
in a way that does not in pinch on the
rights that make us the free people
Manville New Jersey GOP line yeah good
morning speak up sir oh we lost him for
some reason let's move on Gary Indiana
independent line good morning the thing
that concerns me the most is that at the
same time the media is selling this us
this alleged economic recovery which has
yet to reach anyone below fifty thousand
a year and unfortunately the the middle
class as you said Mr Sanders is
shrinking they are taking a look at
taking away our rights now it seems to
me that they're looking more or less to
control the population rather than
control terrorism and they I am scared
we're you know what we're going headlong
into the biggest group or a bunch of
malfeasance that I've seen in Washington
since Watergate and yet nobody's talking
about it or there's always two sides to
the story uh can you comment on that
Gary some of us are talking about it I
mean let's just talk about the economy
and you're right I'm on the Financial
Services Committee and every you know
week somebody from the administration
comes up all the economy is making a
great recovery the reality is that 90%
of American workers today are earning
less in real wages than was the case 30
years ago the gap between the rich and
the poor is growing incredibly white
while dude we have more and more
millionaires and billionaires we have
four million more people living in
poverty than was the case adjust of four
years ago our trade policy is a total
disaster
we're losing millions of good-paying
manufacturing jobs to China where people
are desperate people working for 30
cents an hour now they want to pass more
disastrous trade agreements so while the
economy is in fact disintegrating for
the middle class
while health kisses what situation is
getting worse and worse
you're quite right we have a government
which says no we're not gonna help
people in health care we're not going to
help people in education but we are
certainly are going to be trying to
enforce it give more power to government
authorities to spy on the American
people and I think that is a set of
priorities which is exactly backwards I
think an honest conservatives understand
that that's why we are working with them
with regard to section 215 of the
Patriot Act which is what we're talking
about here how has the Attorney General
responded to this concern he has
indicated that there might be a little
bit of movement on the part of the
administration on the other hand what is
very distressing and and you should know
this and the viewers should notice there
are seven state legislatures in the
United States and over 300 communities
that have gone on record as specks
expressing concerns about the Patriot
Act so all over this country people are
standing up and say hey we want our
constitutional rights and civil
liberties protected and what's happened
in the Senate the Intelligence Committee
not only reauthorized all of the
sunsetted provisions they went even
further giving even more power to the
government to spy on the American people
so they are moving in exactly the wrong
direction I hope that if we win today it
will be a movement back in the direction
of protecting civil liberties Fresno
California GOP line hi could you talk a
little bit about one how the Patriot Act
is applying to Internet Service
Providers because I know there's
something similar to the FBI are there
law enforcement agencies being able to
look into records without warrants and
also whenever I have an Iraq question
there was an article of john burns
co-wrote and New York Times front page
about the training of Iraqi troops and
how that is going and I'm never getting
a clear answer to how combat-ready
troops translates into reducing US
forces and there's just a lot of muddled
talk about that
and I'd love to have clear answers on
that thank you very much in terms of the
internet you've asked an interesting
question section 215 as presently
written allows the FBI to monitor
internet use within libraries and in
fact my last amendment last year
excluded the FBI from that we made a
change because some members are
concerned but the ability of the
government to get into the Internet is
something that I was concerned and on
another issue that we are dealing with
the so called meteor indecency Act there
are people right now in the Senate who
are talking about applying FCC standards
to cable television which conceivably
means that programs like The Sopranos or
Sex in the City or the Jon Stewart Show
or the Bill Maher show literally be
could be taken off and they also want
quote-unquote indecency standards to go
on the internet we're gonna fight that
very very vigorously I mean you know I
hear the president talking a whole lot
about freedom freedom for him he wants
freedom all over the world well you know
what about freedom here in the United
States of America people have the right
to read in this country what they want
to read that's what the First Amendment
is about that's what America is supposed
to be about in terms of Iraqi troops I
read the same article that you did
apparently progress is not being made as
quickly as possible and that is really
unfortunate my own view as somebody who
voted against giving the president
authority to go to war in Iraq and help
lead that effort is I believe we have
got to begin the process of bringing
home our troops as soon as we possibly
can
I think we've got to give support to the
Iraqi people and their military so that
they can defend themselves but I think
the day is coming we've got to stop
bringing our troops back home and doing
some research for a conversation I found
an article written by the Dartmouth
review from a panel session that you
were on at Dartmouth last year and the
Dartmouth review was a student newspaper
I think I cite this section I want you
to respond to Michael Mello co-panelist
a law professor from UVM admitted he
didn't like several sections of the Act
but considered most parts innocuous
the infamous section 215 and had other
heavily impute components as the paper
were mere codifications of pre Patriot
Act statutes and case law when responded
that and then he said in effect the good
professor claimed very little of
substance had actually changed and in a
delicious bit of irony lot lost on any
conservative in the room mellow
explained that most of the abridgements
of Liberty that some quotes were
actually signed into law in the 1970s by
Jimmy Carter I don't agree with the
professor I think the ability of the of
government agents and the FBI to walk
into any library any bookstore in this
country without any probable cause and
then when you go to the librarian and
say I want these records the librarian
cannot make that public at best she can
talk to her attorney if she makes that
public that the FBI's come into her
library she is in violation of the law
as well that is no and that is you can't
see your own records if they're
requested that's what and the individual
under investigation does not know
anything about that as well and with
regard to the innocuous nature and the
fact that it was codifications of prior
standards and had been around since
Jimmy Carter I mean there is a reason
let me tell you that like and I have to
say I don't know how many librarians are
watching the program I have gained a
whole lot of respect for librarians who
I've gone above and beyond the call of
duty you know we think of librarians you
know please get me this book helped me
with this book they are they're saying
they as librarians want to make sure
that people who use their services can
do so without fear and there has been a
huge effort on the part of librarians to
fight this provision
hundreds of thousands of people have
contacted members of Congress on this
issue people have signed petitions and
again all over this country whether
you're progressive or conservatives
people are saying wait a second this
Patriot Act is going too far
Greensboro North Carolina good morning
good morning Mr Sanders look forward to
the possibility that you'll become a
senator for your state thank you very
much
I've just got one little question I'm in
an unfortunate situation I have two
Republican senators
and one Republican representative and
although I call them and let them know
my opinion I wonder just how much that
has to do and I'm just one more person
in my shake who does not get
representation well what would you
suggest that we do with with her with
wit with our desires with what we want
well you've asked a very important
question and I think many people in this
country feel increasingly alienated from
the political process the standard of
living is going down they don't have any
health care they're losing their
pensions their concerns about the war in
Iraq and who is listening to them
yesterday Susan I think this was in
these papers of the Republican Party
held a fundraising dinner and they
raised millions and millions of dollars
it is very clear to me and I think many
Americans that Congress listens to
millionaires and billionaires gives tax
breaks to those people and does nothing
about raising the minimum wage or taking
care of the needs of ordinary people I
think ordinary people have got to be
involved now in changing the political
culture of our country if we do in
Vermont I have to tell you I do dozens
and dozens of town meetings all over the
state and unlike the President of the
United States I allow people to come to
the meetings who actually disagree with
me because that's what I think democracy
is about so I think hold meetings invite
your local representatives say look
we're gonna have a meeting on the
Patriot Act we're having a meeting on
the economy we're having a meeting on
the war in Iraq we've got up a hundred
people out we want you to be there come
on out and talk to us answer questions
that is what democracy is about and I
would agree with the caller that the
fewer Americans feel that that is in
fact what's happening Bernie Sanders was
first elected to the US House of
Representatives in 1990 that makes him
the longest serving independent in the
history of the House of Representatives
next telephone call for him is New York
City
I'm sorry Great Falls Virginia go ahead
hello thank you for announcing to the
terrorists how they can sit and wait and
go into libraries and bookstores now
with your wonderful amendment
like to ask you what country are you
representing because I'm not really sure
if representative America sir
when we have a country where a
construction worker can't hang in the
American flag on the table for Flag Day
but god forbid we we don't we let handle
with white gloves Koran which we gave to
the prisoners at Guantanamo Bay then I'd
like to know what the hell country
you're presenting sir if you're not
representing mine well I believe I am
representing the United States of
America I believe that I'm representing
the vast majority of the people who are
concerned about terrorism but are not
going to throw the Constitution of the
United States in the toilet bowl in that
fight we can fight terrorism we can
protect basic rights and in my view what
America is precisely about is that
people can read a book without worrying
that the government and Big Brother are
monitoring their reading habits so you
and I sir have a difference of opinion
on that Pine Mountain Georgia
independent line good morning to you
good morning I just want to say that I
think the citizens of Vermont to just
thank their lucky stars they have
somebody like Bernie Sanders working for
them it's like this man has come off of
Mars anyway I'm a big fan of Bernie
Sanders I live in Georgia but by way of
New York I was in New York or all my
life
and I totally agree with with him and I
just wanted to say I think he's doing a
wonderful job for all of us as citizens
something that I feel this
administration just totally doesn't care
about I feel like as far as losing our
rights he's totally right I mean this is
what Hitler did after the Reichstag fire
in in Germany before World War two
started where he told the citizens well
you have to give up your rights so we
can fight terrorism I mean once we give
up all right that's it I mean the ball
game is over we already have lost so
many of our rights and I feel that
Bernie Sanders and people the few people
that are like him in Congress are our
greatest advocates the advocates of the
citizens of the United States who
understand what this country is all
about what we fought for during during I
mean this country is based on dissent
and and wanting those rights
the people during the Revolutionary War
fought for it he really understands that
and I just want to thank you so much for
being the kind of representative you are
and keeping our rights intact
well thank you and let me just say I
mean I'm doing what I can do there are
many other members of Congress and again
I want to reiterate this is not just a
progressive effort we have a lot of
honest conservatives who are doing a
tremendous job people who are 98% of the
issues we are on very different sides of
of how we feel about those issues but on
the issue of protecting constitutional
rights you're seeing a lot of
progressives and conservatives coming
together in fact a number of the critics
have formed the Patriot Act reform
caucus in the house representatives some
of those leaders in addition to Mr
Sanders include jeff flake of Arizona
Republican Ron Paul of Texas Republican
and Jerry Nadler of New York what about
the Senate in the Senate there is
opposition as well they're moving along
a different tack but you're gonna see
people standing up I believe in the
Senate to protect civil liberties as
well and how would this amendment today
to this particular spending bill work
its way through the process the way it
works its way through the process is
normal way if this amendment passes it
will then go to conference committee and
we'll be doing everything we can to make
sure that it stays in the final in the
final bill and is there a single
equivalent of for any Sanders on the
Senate side who is a lead on this issue
Russ Feingold among many others has been
playing a good role New York City good
morning good morning just to define
myself to this discussion I am white and
I came to the United States the height
of the apartheid era from South Africa I
was a young girl and after a few days
here I had an epiphany I could see that
I could read anything and buy any book
without fear of retribution because
South Africa used the six Prix as a
pretext for loss of the risks and
invading homes and libraries and when I
saw that I could read anything without
fear I felt that I was truly free for
the first time although as a white South
African they told me if sensibly I was
free and
I support Bernie Sanders in every way
and hope that this is that he's
successful in his efforts thank you
you know but thank you very much : the
Kolo reminds I think me and all of us
something about our history I think what
concerns me about what the Bush
administration is doing is they're
saying trust us
I mean we're only gonna go after the bad
guys you don't have to worry but I think
we don't have to look too far back any
further than 1960s or where one of the
bad guys who was under FBI investigation
was a man to whom we now celebrate once
a year Martin Luther King jr. he was
considered a bad guy his phone was being
tapped so in a nation of law where we
have a constitution in a bill of rights
the issue is not trust the
administration trust any administration
we have got to have laws that protect
basic constitutional rights and and
that's what we're fighting for how many
comments on the hearing of mr.
Sensenbrenner Committee on the Patriot
Act renewal and what happened there yeah
I I wasn't there but it's again
indicative of something that concerns me
as I understand that mr. Sensenbrenner
did not like some of the testimony that
was that he was hearing and he gobbled
it down and he walked out that is not
the way you should be treating witnesses
that come before a congressional
committee you have to give them respect
even if you don't like what they say
believe me I go to many committee
hearings I'm a ranking member on one of
the financial services subdivide on't
like you don't you're not rude you don't
say sorry goodbye I'm leaving and that
again tells the American people that are
those people who have the power now
gonna be tolerant are they gonna allow
different points of view to be heard so
I think what missed the sense of Brennan
did was very unfortunate Greenwich
Connecticut
good morning Democrats fine yes and so I
think we're putting a muzzle on the
American people and this is a sad
witness for to our military being rented
out to crush any interest of these are
corporate powers understand witnessing
of our military into a mercenary force
to control the world's financial
interests it's all it's just another
bankers war it's a-you know I just came
back from
from Germany and they have a green party
over there parliamentary form of
government where the foreign minister of
Germany is a member of the Green Party
and the there's a communist interest
there we had the three percent of the
American people voting for the Green
Party and 48 for the Democrats and the
Republicans we need a third party if the
green party was represented in hundred
percent type of parliamentary government
they would the bidding war over there
and this this Bush administration I can
go back to what was so Lincoln said
corporations are being enthroned at an
era of corruption in high places will
follow and the money power of the
country will endeavour to belong a frame
by working on the prejudices of the
people until the wealth is aggravated in
a few hands and the Republic is
destroyed we don't have a republic here
we don't have democracy we have a
corporate own two-party system that's
controlled by these by the money supply
that's and I like your response on this
histogram Mr Sanders I respect you very
much I mean all don't know the gentleman
said a lot all done I'll say is I am
very proud of my state which had the
courage to go outside of the two-party
system and elect the first independent
elected to Congress in 40 years you have
been pretty critical of the Republican
leaders in the House of Representatives
during our conversation this morning but
let me have you put into context the
fact that your amendment is back on the
floor and of 36 amendments to this state
and justice appropriations bill today
yours has the longest time allotted for
debate so how do you square those two
well I put something under I wanted a
long I talked to the ranking member on
that because this is an issue of such
importance that I wanted both sides to
be able to make their case what you're
saying is true Susan but the reality is
that there are many other very very
important bills that come down on the
floor where amendments are simply not
allowed bankruptcy built the case in
point and I think very few people would
dispute that the Republican leadership
has allowed fewer amendments or
debate on important issues then has been
the case in the past I would refer you
not only to what happened to me last
year where Tom DeLay kept the voting
rolls open an extra 20 minutes probably
one of the most important bills that was
passed in the last several years was the
so-called Medicare prescription drug
bill which I thought was a disaster
written by the pharmaceutical industry
at the end of regulation time those of
us who were against that bill had won
the Republican leadership kept that bill
open three hours from 3 o'clock in the
morning to 6 o'clock in the morning to
twist arms to get the votes they need
that does not sound to me like a very
fair and democratic process Long Island
on the GOP line you're on the air good
morning yes I do a congressman I usually
applaud the work that everybody does but
it talks me to applaud when I you
constantly hear people talking so badly
about the other side of the aisle and I
just might I have a comment and then a
question my comment is is that we really
need you guys to work together so much
better than what you guys have been
because I mean we elect you guys to the
office you guys are supposed to do our
bidding what we want how we want it what
we think we need and how our future how
we think our future should go you know
not one elected official has ever done
what his body of people want them to do
they simply follow the lobbyists and
what the big-money men that put them
there want them to do I mean like if
you're it's like you're talking about
the meeting before if you're not even
there at the meeting how can you comment
on it and why does it seem that any of
the laws of bills being passed through
the Congress and through Senate are
benefiting the rich for instance hs2 56
swept through Congress with almost a
little to no fight from any
representatives there HS 256 is one of
the worst things that reminds so what
was a 256 making chapter 11 in chapter
13 bankruptcy bill yes you're right
difficult young one that was made up by
the credit card that's exactly right
that's exactly right all right let me
just jump in sir I mean what I want to
reiterate is that the effort today that
that I am bringing forth has the support
of people who have very different
political points we are trying to reach
out and find common ground on this issue
the point that you made about big money
controlling what goes on in the
bankruptcy bill it being a case in point
is exactly right whether it is the
pharmaceutical in the shoe the credit
card companies big banks the insurance
companies almost every piece of
legislation that comes down on the floor
of the house that has financial
implications is controlled and pushed by
these guys who make huge campaign
contributions I think sir if you check
my record we have stood up tall most
every big financial institution that has
pushed legislation on to the floor of
the house
some of us and believe me not just me
are trying to represent the middle class
and working people and not big money and
I think you check my record out you'll
find that's the case Orlando independent
line you're on the air good morning
thank you for taking my call Mr Sanders
I first found out about you through the
documentary outfoxed and I understand
that you're one of the people who was
very vocal about corporate control of
the media
I have studied mass media sort of past
couple of months and it concerns me
about the information I gather from news
organizations I'm asking you is there
any legislation out there that you would
like to see passed that would help our
news organizations and if you feel keep
the public better informed thank you
that's the wonderful question there may
be some time Susan we can come back and
spend an hour on that one because that's
a huge issue here's the story in America
today what you're seeing are fewer and
fewer giant multimedia conglomerates
controlling what we see here and read
when you turn on NBC it's owned by
General Electric and you turn on CBS
it's owned by Viacom you turn on ABC
it's owned by Disney when you turn on a
fox it's owned by Rupert Murdoch who is
a right-wing billionaire by the way let
me compliment c-span for one for being
in my view one of the bright lights in
terms of mass media where different
points of view can be heard I think that
they do an excellent job I got involved
in this fight because as bad as the
current situation is where fewer and
fewer media conglomerates control what
we hear see and read the president wants
to deregulate media even more and allow
fuel companies to
control the flow of information under
the president's plan which fortunately
we were able to sidetrack it has not
been implemented you can have
communities in America where you will
have one corporation owning the
television stations owning the radio
stations owning the newspaper only the
weeklies owning the cable network in the
United States of America this is not
Soviet Union this is the United States
of America so I think the fact that
you're seeing big money interest
filtering the news that the American
people get is a huge issue to my mind
when you talk about domestic issues the
most significant issue facing America is
what I call the collapse of the middle
class the fact that despite an increase
in technology and worker productivity
the average American is working longer
hours for low wages why is that how
often do you see that issue being
discussed on television how often do we
note that the United States is the only
country in the industrialized world that
doesn't have a national health care
program guaranteeing health care to some
of the most important issues facing the
American people get almost no discussion
at all on commercial television or in
fact in many of our newspapers so I
think this whole issue of corporate
control of media is a huge issue and we
are working hard on a number of pieces
of legislation not the least of which is
to making sure that there is not further
deregulation so the fewer companies
control of the flow of information I
take one last call from mr. Sanders it's
from Flushing New York GOP line yeah
please don't cut me off I just wanted to
say to mr. Sanders that we're living now
at a time we are them we are so
prosperous this country that everybody's
trying to get here well not only are we
prosperous but yes there is a disparity
there is a problem between the rich
getting richer and the middle class
isn't moving up this quick but it will
it will and what I'm trying to say to
you is I want to say to the American
people look look at your your car in
your garage see if it's new or old look
at the house you're able to buy and see
how many people are unemployed we are
there's more people employed in America
today than
ever has been yes there is at the fact
and secondly there are more everybody is
trying to get into this country and
socialized medicine people from Canada
come here for an operation there isn't
any place in the world that can beat us
yeah we have to do better and our our
government isn't the very best but at
least they're making some progress
they're saying something like John Kerry
I watched and listened and wanted to see
what he had to say because before this
election I was independent and I wanted
to see he had nothing to say and the
Democrats right now have nothing to say
maybe the Republicans have made moves
and they have made some mistakes but at
least they're making some moves and if
you're talking about socialized medicine
anywhere else in the world it has it
cannot compare to our system here
standard of living okay let me just just
very briefly respond to that
unemployment is not terribly high
although it's higher than people think
it is dependent because of the way we
calculate it but the reality is that
despite an explosion of worker
productivity the average American worker
today is working longer hours for lower
wages in the last four years I have to
inform the kola that four million more
Americans left the ranks of middle class
and became poor and that in the last
five years since George Bush has been
president there is a net loss of
private-sector jobs that all of the job
growth under the Bush administration has
been among government jobs and a lot of
that has to do with our disastrous trade
policies which is sending good-paying
jobs to China and other low-wage
countries while the new jobs being
created in the United States are mostly
low wage jobs Walmart jobs with poor
benefits I would strongly disagree with
the caller in terms of her assessment
about how the economy is going I should
also add that while there is no question
that if you have the money the United
States has a fantastic health care
system but if you are middle class if
you are working class if you are lower
income person
you are having a difficult time getting
the quality or access to the health care
that you need Mr Sanders amendment is on
c-span website c-span org if you'd like
to see the text of it and a reminder
that will be providing live coverage of
the house beginning at 10:00 Eastern
Time this morning and his his amendment
is part of the debate over the science
state justice a spending bill this year
and he has 40 hour 45 hours